Dr Jordan B Peterson has put together  another incisive commentary wherein he  tweeted the Twitter files are worse than  Nixon's Watergate it's hard to say with  a straight face the Twitter files have  completely flopped completely flopped  I've done a bunch of long-form analyzes  of the Twitter files on my YouTube  channel but you can find at youtube.com  the davidpackman show one of the big  differences by the way between Nixon's  Watergate and the Twitter files is that  the Twitter files expose no crime that's  a major difference what these folks are  doing is the Twitter files flopped so  hard that they're having to over  compensate by acting like it is the  biggest scandal in history sort of like  when Trump talked about Obama gate Obama  gate it's been going on for a long time  and then we never learned what it was  because it doesn't exist that's what  they're doing it's pathetic it's a joke  we shouldn't be surprised